Thank You minister and Prime Minister if
you're extremely warm welcome Bonjour -
Bonjour cara de bonne fête Canada just
we sell more her dead de retour or
Canada
so pay a money peek at that washes the
prawns Amir Luke Annette I'm excited to
be able to share this to Catherine
because she has told me
she's told me that she feels exactly the
same way she heard about Canada not from
her parents but from her grandfather a
wonderful man who passed away last year
but who held this country dear to his
heart for he trained in Alberta he
trained in Alberta as a young pilot
during the Second World War to be here
on Canada Day a day of unity a day of
coming together as families and as a
nation is even more special for us to
mark today my grandmother the Queen of
Canada
has asked me to convey her warmest good
wishes to the people of Canada and her
happy and abiding memories of being on
Parliament Hill with the Duke of
Edinburgh one year ago the Queen has
taken a great interest in the themes and
program of our tour and looks forward to
following our progress as it unfolds
speaking of families out of loved ones
far away this is an important moment for
Canada for this month the service men
and women of the Canadian Forces ceased
their combat role in Afghanistan this
draws to a close an episode of which all
Canadians can be immensely proud
our armed forces have always led the
world in rallying to the defense of
freedom from Vimy Ridge and Juno Beach
through Korea and the Balkans to
Kandahar province the sacrifices of
Canadians has been universally revered
and respected Nubians Jemaine is he Oh
Canada lay Canadian la Commedia de
menthe OSI layer force earlier determine
ashore gee salut Lucca Raj they keep the
secure idea reconstruction or Quebec or
Manitoba Saskatchewan on Alberta
Catherine and I are also thrilled at
excited by the prospects of the next
eight days
especially of being part of the Canadian
family it will be an adventure that
we'll never forget
merci Canada merci lady fancier do
Canada laughs Amy Canadian bonne fête
Canada happy birthday Canada